this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block for that pizza
you need
I'm heading it's a coma this weekend and
a Spokane to the comedy clubs there and
I will see you there
let's go there you go they coming in boy
and that is it they coming in
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go boy that's it baby
crack any of your cousin baby crack in
to your cousin it is that time it's
March 12 and it's daylight savings time
man did you feel that what a friggin
speed bump daddy's huh you know you got
regular life going on everything's chill
you know you maybe you and the lady got
a plan to do a little you know do a
little dirty game a close freeze tag
with each other a little freaking bang
bang by bang bang and then suddenly you
realize I got one less hour of sleep
coming at me and for me man my entire
world falls apart like everything
everything fell apart I went and bought
cigarettes I bought one of them things
of um you know them six those puddin
packs them snack packs they got about
one of them chocolatey hitters bruh
one of them six pack of chocolatey um
you know jell-o children's snack packs
instead I did I'm cracking into those
and you know blowing Winston's and I'm
just going through it all and now I'm so
angry he had the crazy thing was I was
so angry that I'm losing that I'm not
going to get an hour of sleep that now
I'm too angry to go to sleep so I was
just oh and then here's what I'll do
I'll get angry and I'll be like oh I'm
okay world okay world you're gonna take
away an hour of sleep guess what
I'm not gonna brush my teeth tonight
that's this weird game that goes on in
my head you know like okay universe you
don't want daddy to get that extra big
sixty of ninety night night then I'm not
gonna brush
teeth you'll see I'm gonna wake up I'm
gonna wake up straight up just spraying
that Grim Reaper heat right at people's
eyeballs but that's what that's it you
know like the world gives a [ __ ] that
I'm gonna do that the world doesn't care
bro go to bed you idiot but not me
not me man I got a you know I got a I
gotta get angry and get crooked so then
I'm bent out now I'm bent out and I'm
having all smoke nine Winston's and blue
through five and them kitty snackers and
now I'm a creep now I'm a part you know
now the neighbors are look you know and
they have these people have a a balcony
that's kind of over for mine on the
third floor and they always look down on
me and it's weird because since they do
like physically look down on me it feels
like they also looked down on me you
know emotionally and you know
subjectively I think I don't know if
those are the right two words to use
there but guess what you know what I'm
talking about
you know let's don't get each on each
other's backs about all these words but
I feel like they looked down on me and
last night man the lady caught me man
the lady caught me out there just
leaking with emotion just bent out you
know just frickin just just heavy huff
in these Winston's these Winston
cigarettes and I'm blowing through them
that chocolate is six so yeah I mean I
don't you know I don't fare well with
change obviously you know upfront I
don't but in the end I know it's what's
best
you know I know change is always the
best man I know it's scary but you know
change is scary but I think it's always
the best you know I was thinking about
because you know this morning I got up I
didn't get out till probably 11:30 you
know because I don't even get to bed or
probably 3:40 you know and sheer fury
and I didn't brush my teeth you know
even though it just affects me when I do
that [ __ ] but whatever bro
you know so anyway I was bent out I made
it into the day and then I started
remembering I remember back when I was
young they had you know I used to live
with a
family when I was young and the daddy
got I lived with a couple of families
and one of them the daddy got uh you
know he'd wake up in the middle of the
night and eat tostitos chips and do some
adult masturbation on the computer and
that's when families usually just had a
family computer remember and sometimes I
go out there and try to sneak out there
to get a snack you know because the
family computer was out there in the
kitchen and the you know kitchen and it
was a data they had a you know a
comfortable home and they had you know a
family computer out there that was kind
of in this you know big room near the
kitchen and the daddy be over there you
know breaking himself down you know just
treating himself like a real like a
champ
you know just patting himself on the
patting his penis on the back you know
you know what I'm saying
and and so I would try but I would want
that snack you know cuz when you wake up
at night there's very little if you want
a snack once you get that word snack in
your head there's very little that will
suffice
it's like you gotta have that snack and
you think oh I could just have two
glasses of water and try to trick my
stomach but no but if you but if you lay
awake like another 2 or 3 minutes it is
snack only and so that's where I was I
was in snack [ __ ] only mode and so now
I got to get a snack right and I
remember going out there and the daddy
sometime would be out there you know and
he'd be doing self pleasure and look I'm
not nah I don't think that's crazy you
know a lot of people I mean I think it's
crazy if he you know if a man for an
adult is to go towards children
masturbating you know if somebody comes
at running at me and they're mad and
they're jerking off at the same time I'm
gonna [ __ ] kick him in the neck dude
okay I'm gonna chop them down and I got
an axe bro
I'm about to cherry tree that cat like
the first president baby you know saying
I'm chopping them down if somebody comes
running at me in his masturbating at the
same time they're out even though also I
do feel like now that I mentioned that
that should be an Asian Olympic sport
you telling me okay be honest
and it doesn't have to be Asian but this
is something that that would start off
probably in Japan jerking off running
and jerking off at the same time right
you got to hit the finish line and bust
out I mean that is if that ain't the
next Bellator you know if they don't if
they don't expand into a new realm I
mean that's the new professional bull
riding right they are doing that but uh
but anyhow what I was saying was that so
then it would be this crazy game I had
to sneak over to the fridge and get in
that fridge without getting it making
the dad turn his back cuz he said he was
on the internet on early pornography you
know this was early pornography this is
when you know [ __ ] was loading and you
had to relax and you know he'd have some
Tostitos and a little bit of sauce out
there and he's just hitting you know
he's taking each each one of these
toasts eats and just mobbing into that
salsa and then he's just grilling you
know in the whole time I'm [ __ ] like
kind of crawling towards me because if
he looks across the room he can't see me
because there are counters but if I
stand up he can see me get in the fridge
so I'm just like elbow crawling through
the frickin kitchen you know I'm just
elbow crawling through the kitchen like
a real snake and he would be event on
here you know a page would be loading
because that's when he'd hit them chips
so he's just you know he's mobbing into
these tossed eats and I'm you know and
I'm just uh just elbow crawling towards
that refrigerator and him eating the
Tostitos are making me so much hungrier
oh my god everyone he put into his mouth
was just making me hungry and also
knowing that there was pornography on
the computer was making me you know feel
kind of flush in my in my crotch so I
mean I'm going through a lot and all I
wanted was a snack like originally when
I left the room they let me stay in a
bedroom at their home when I left the
room I was chill but once I hit the
kitchen I saw the glow of that computer
in the distance you know I knew daddy
was over there popping then that means I
had to you know get I had to sneak up to
the fridge now some of you guys are
already wondering well once you hit
the fridge you're gonna open the door
and the lights gonna come out he's gonna
see the light you're right you're right
but I see but here's the thing about
some fridges some fridges um they have a
if you open the door a little bit you
can sneak your hand in there and push
that little lever because there's a
little lever that the door pushes
against and that's what turns the light
on and off it's just a lever you know
just like a push lever and so when that
door if you if you're careful you slowly
move the door up you can get your hand
up there to hold that lever and keep the
light out so that was my saving grace
man
so I'm [ __ ] you know I got that door
open just a touch I hit that thing I hit
the lever I'm safe from the light I got
that door open and then I hear the chips
stop and I'm like [ __ ] you know but then
I hear the chips kind of start up again
and I'm like ha must have been an ad
popped up you know that he had to close
or something
so now man I'm getting I'm getting more
and more robust you know Fiat thing
about the crotch you know cuz I'm
thinking about pornography and when
you're young and you're you know this
was high school excuse me I'm having a
little coffee if you hear me but in high
school man if you start thinking my
pornography I mean your dick turns into
a dang rudder I mean this thing I could
have I mean I could have dragged this
thing to the dirt and and uh and you
know hold a hundred yards of field I
mean this thing was I could have tilled
soil with with this rudder I was jacking
back then you know because i was dick
heavy back then and in any house so I
get my I'm now I'm kind of in the fridge
but it's dark you know it's kind of dark
on that side of the arm of that side of
the of this room this big room because
it's the kitchen and then it goes out
into the dining room it's all one big
open space you know these people had a
little bit of cash on them and so now
I'm trying to get in that frigerator you
know and that but the thing is these
people have had a little bit of money
and when you got a little bit of money
if you ever been in a rich person's
frigerator Dan got
[ __ ] here's what they got they got a
little thing of like summer sausage
fancy summer sausage from somewhere
Italy or somewhere else they have olives
bruh six or seven jars of Olives
they had a I remember they had a wine
opener in the fridge but no wine in
there like what the [ __ ] dude
you got to have money if you keep eye
opener in the fridge what else they had
some fancy cheese on a board but that
kind of cheese that if you're from where
I'm from you don't eat you don't eat
that kind of cheese you know that cheese
feels like a trap the second you taste
it it feels like you're sucking on the
it feels like you're sucking on the the
it feel like you're sucking on a the tit
of like somebody who somebody's body is
full of us science experiments that's
what it feels like if you eat some of
them fancy cheese you know brigadiere
and what else they had Joel a different
kind of cheeses you know rare cheddar
and so anyway I'm [ __ ] rightful you
know trying to get this [ __ ] dude and
then I hear the daddy starts you know he
starts chirping on himself and I'm
trying not to hear this [ __ ] man cuz I
don't mind look look man yes the man was
older than me that's fine but we're
still men you know I'm saying I at that
point I masturbate as well so it's not
like you know I don't know the mean
streets of you know of you know of body
sounds you know I'm saying I've been out
there so but I'm trying to [ __ ]
trying to fill my belly dude and you
have no idea man how hard it is to
[ __ ] bro I had a mouth full of olives
right and this dude starts getting into
it and it's so hard to eat olives abroad
well somebody else's you know while
somebody else is jerking off and it's uh
and and I just remember having that what
else I had some they would have
asparagus in there but they always had
it under this foil they had like one of
them glassware a big casserole dish and
then foil and it was just asparagus so
that foil man even though you don't
think it makes a loud noise when it's
the only
always in town in the middle of the
night it's loud so you got to carefully
lift that foil and then ease your hand
in that pan and get you one of them uh a
spare a guy you know one of them and
then you got a slurp that sucker dude so
now I remember at one point I had two
asparagus in my mouth and this dude's
across the room you know just you know
working that inverse ice you know
working that you know working that
iceberg bro working that meaty iceberg
and I I mean it's hard to eat asparagus
while somebody is also masturbating in
the distance and so it was uh but what I
wanted to get at man saw him went off on
a tangent what I was trying to get out
here was there were times at that home
these people had a nice home and had a
lot of windows and stuff around that
whole area and they didn't really have
neighbors at the time so and the windows
looked out onto you know kind of
marshlands and stuff and it was very
beautiful and I remember at times in
that home I would get up in the morning
after you know after the daylight after
we set the clocks back or whatever and I
would see how bright it was in the
morning and this is so the time that we
do it in the winter in September or
whatever and I would say it was the
first time that I noticed daylight
savings time that's what I'm trying to
say is that I remember the first time
that I ever noticed daylight savings
time I mean I remember when I was a kid
I remember saying you know we set the
clocks and but I never really understood
kind of how it worked and then there was
one you know a beautiful morning not
that morning when I was out there trying
to get something to eat
but when I was staying living with the
same people there was a there was a
beautiful morning where I walked out and
and the and the the you know the just
the it was so bright and it was so early
it was like 6:00 a.m. and it was and it
was bright and it was you could see all
the marsh and you know see all these
egrets and all these beautiful birds and
you could even see probably a gator in
the distance just creeping along the
water out there and uh and I remember
being like wow it's bright really early
and I remember that that the dad had
told me a well this you know daylight
savings time just happened and so when
it switches you know you can really get
a feel for the morning out here and and
I remember that just being the first
time that I noticed daylight savings
time you know just noticed how you know
sometime you get a bigger dose of the
morning and then the rest of the year
you get a bigger dose of the evening and
so now we get a bigger dose of the
evening and I know and I know it's
awesome it specially like in the Midwest
and stuff you get you know there's
nothing nicer than when it kind of cools
off in the Midwest and it's just
starting to you know you can sit outside
on the porch or outside in your yard and
you can see the fireflies and you know
the kids are running around and you got
the fight you know chasing the fireflies
and you can start to hear the you know
you could hear Mother Nature just
chirping she got all those insects and
all those night critters that start
chirping in the distance and there's
nothing I remember that was more fun you
know being young or being a kid or even
living in Louisiana when when it would
be just cool enough to sit outside or
just not hot enough and you could sit
outside in that extra hour of sunlight
and I remember those being usually
really special times you got to spend
with your with your family or with your
friends or it just there was something
comfortable about those times you know
when the work was over and people got to
enjoy each other's company and I really
really really enjoyed that I really
enjoyed those times but happy daylight
saving time do you know it's daylight
saving time you know that well you
should know that and you do now and
actually give you little bit of
information because I looked it up I was
like why did this happen you know this
it really is a crazy thing you know just
all of a sudden to switch everything for
an hour and I know I always knew that
you know there were you know there were
times when farming and for farming
communities it's better because you can
work later in the day and you know I
used to farm ice just I used to work on
a soybean corn cotton Milo farm outside
of Vidalia Louisiana and
across the river across the Mississippi
River from Natchez over there in the
Mississippi Delta I'm not in the Delta
but in a delta off of the levee and and
so man I remember when it was you know
summer you know riding along the levee
and being able to see the sunset and
like I don't know man I just remember I
always always always really loved that
time and I remember you know that that
would give us extra time in the day to
you know run spray rigs or fertilizer
rigs and to take care of just whatever
needed to be taken care of man and I
started out as a farmhand and then I
worked
they had a migrant worker I guess and we
shared a room for a while
Latino gentleman and and it was fun man
you know I really really enjoyed my time
there and that was in Natchez
Mississippi or outside of there but
that's daylight savings time in a saving
time sorry and I'm just going to tell
you a little bit about it they like
saving time while Germany and Austria
were the first countries to use DST in
1916 is a little-known fact that a few
hundred Canadians beat the German Empire
by eight years on July 1st 1908 the
residents of Port Arthur Ontario would
as today popularly popularly referred to
as Thunder Bay turn their clocks forward
by one hour to start the world's first
daylight saving time period other
locations in Canada soon followed suit
however the idea did not catch on
globally until Germany introduced
daylight savings time in 1916 clocks and
the German Empire and in its ally
Austria were turned ahead by one hour on
April 30th 1916 two years in a World War
one the rationale was to minimize the
use of artificial lighting to save fuel
for the war effort within a few weeks
the idea was followed by the United
Kingdom and France and many other
countries most of them reverted the
standard time after World War one and it
was until the next world war that
daylight savings time made his return in
most of Europe so that's some history of
all daylight saving time you know it's
wild the things that war will make you
do I mean
or maybe those people think man we have
to conserve whatever it is you know our
fuel for lanterns you know I don't think
you had electricity then I don't know do
you know so you know if they had
electricity they had to shut it down but
that's the reason why that's what it
says right there and that's just you
know that could be real it could not be
real but that's a little mo information
what else man um the song on the come in
that was by Brad love Levine and uh and
he's a fan of the podcast and he made
that hit man and that's a beautiful I'm
like I'm gonna drop back into that thing
for one more second that really is a
nice rift it's March 12
[Music]
[Laughter]
then
I guess that hype man that gets that
hype thank you guys for being here with
me on this past weekend thank you guys
for the support remember to subscribe on
YouTube we're almost at 30,000 which
means at 30,000 subscribers I have to
I'm gonna put up I don't have to but I
am well I said I would so I'm gonna put
up a new stand-up comedy clip that's not
up there so and you know sometimes if
you wonder why a lot of comedians don't
put up extra clips it's because you know
you want to save some of that material
for when you go to see people live and
for if you get offered a comedy special
a lot of people I ask why you know deal
you're not you haven't done another
special not because I don't want to you
know I just haven't been offered one you
know it's a tough business out here it's
a tough business and and that's what it
is
you know I knew it was tough whenever I
got into it I didn't know that it was
like this you know I do feel sometimes I
feel you know I started to feel
especially like after like in the past
two years I started to feel that you
know that Hollywood doesn't want any
real southern white people you know and
and some of that you know could just be
well you know those are just your
thoughts and your ideas but then a lot
of some of you see that proof out there
you know there hasn't been there hasn't
been a southern white person on network
television in 20 years I can't even name
a popular you know Blake Shelton is like
the only southerner I think that's even
really on television do can you imagine
like right now because I know the
Academy Awards the ratings were like the
lowest ever from what I've heard anyway
I don't know if you know a lot of the
new stuff is true but anyway that's what
I heard
so if that if that's true then a mat
like and Blake Shelton is the only thing
that Pete like you know Hollywood feels
like you know we all we can go to him
you know can you imagine how many offers
Blake Shelton is getting right now it
has to be unbelievable mark my words
right now Blake Shelton will be hosting
one of the huge
shows next year I'm just gonna put it
out there I think that's what's gonna
happen because you know money isn't
loyal you know and and you know money
when when when it starts to affect their
advertising you know then Hollywood you
think will make some changes but yeah I
feel like it's tough for me sometimes
out here just because it's like they
don't you know I just wish they would
have told me when I was young and you
start having dreams you want to go to
Los Angeles and you want to chase your
dreams and you know they say come here
and everybody's welcome and you know
this is a place about you know love and
about you know equality and inclusion
and then I get here and a lot of times I
feel like you know that that that's not
the case really you know especially
recently I guess and you know a lot of
you know people just get so divided
politically and there's not that many
people out here like me so I think you
know you just I don't know I feel like I
feel like I you know I was talking to
Joey Diaz about and he said you just got
to work harder you know you just got to
work harder and and you know I was so
grateful to hear him say that if you
don't listen to Joey Diaz is Joey cocoa
Diaz and he is he's one of a kind and
he's a real soothsayer and he's just a
he's just a special he's a special
person
he's a conduit and some people are
conduits you know and they are just kind
of pathways of of good energy and he's
one of those people but he said maybe
you did you know they're gonna make you
work harder for it
and so you know whether they you know
while they're Hollywood you know because
look Hollywood does not pick the most
entertaining people anymore Hollywood
picks you know I don't know what I have
no idea how they choose a lot of the
make a lot of the choices they make
because they're just so disconnected it
seems like from what's just entertaining
but with that said you know I can have
that point of view and still be out here
and you know and that's why we start
this past weekend and that's why we
start the channels and that's why we do
our own thing you noted
be free from those bonds you know be
free from you know the man you know and
I'm sure it's the same reason why a lot
of you guys have started your own
business or if you're you know if you're
you know if you're working for someone
else right now you have dreams down the
road of doing your own thing just for
that freedom you know for that peace of
mind you know and that's uh and you know
and I guess I should just be grateful
because I mean I'm grateful to at least
be able to work around some of the
people that you know that I you know
that really admire and I'm grateful that
you know some there are people in my
circle of friends who are heroes of mine
which is pretty unique you know but it's
but one thing I did start to think man
this is and this was a real thought that
I had was so I started to feel like wow
because of where I'm from you know
because I mean look it's no it's no lie
that Hollywood has just to me it feels
like really rejected anybody from like a
rural community or seems to you know
they just make us all like we're you
know all racists are all it's like they
have nobody to blame anymore so it's
like oh well let's just blame poor white
people you know we can make fun of them
for how they sound or because their rate
you know we can say that they're all
racist or they're all ignorant that [ __ ]
makes me mad man really does it makes
you mad cuz I would never do that to
somebody you know and to be a uh you
know a place where people say like come
out here and live your dreams and like
equality and you know like all of this
stuff and then you get here and you feel
that and then some of that's real
because I feel it you know I feel people
like ah this [ __ ] if this guy succeeds
it breaks our whole idea of what we
think works you know what we think the
world is like so but you know what it
made me think man this is real is that I
was well thinking wow and look some of
this is like you know I don't think this
all the time and I have a ton of moments
where I'm like [ __ ] it let's go I'm
doing my [ __ ] no matter what but also
this is a place where I you know that I
have to you'll have to recognize and
rationalize sometimes
and even if it's and there's a there
could be a reality that's not a true but
it's still a fear that pops into my head
so I still have to work through that
fear so I can be comfortable here and
continue to do my work but it made me
think wow because of where I'm from or
because of how I sound or because of how
I look
you know I can't get work or I'm not
welcoming to certain circles and then it
made me think man that must be what a
lot of diverse entertainers black Latino
entertainers have felt like for a while
you know that I mean it just it
immediately just like holy [ __ ] man this
is what that feels like that because of
the way you look or the way you sound or
the way you know the way you you know or
where you're from that you're not
welcome that you aren't part of the plan
you know it feels like you know
Hollywood sometimes it feels like they
just wish people like me would just die
off you know are people who like me who
they think I am but most of the people
that I grew up around were good people
you know and they weren't racist and
they weren't ignorant you know maybe
they didn't go to some fancy school but
they weren't ignorant people like yeah
there's some [ __ ] straight-up Muppets
out there no doubt but there was a lot
of really good people as well so anyway
I don't mean to get off into that into
that boneyard man but that's some of the
struggle that I have you know or that I
fear you know and that could just be a
fear you know that's sometimes it's a
scary thing about our brains it's like
it can create such real fears that we
don't know if it's a fear or if it's
real that's the dark arts isn't it
really is huh you know I asked you guys
who listens to the show and I got a call
right here from a young lady that
listened so I just wanted to uh I wanted
to put her up right now let's see if we
can catch in thank you hey tio
I was just getting me a call but you
know who's out here listening to this
past weekend part
ooh okay and I'm gonna do this like a
wine you ever um you know when you get a
wine and they like spin it around your
nose there's always some dude dressed in
a tuxedo that kind of swirls
around your nose you know and I'm not
gonna say that that guy you know
probably prefers the company of men or
but he that guy might be kind of wild
you know but um you know or think it's a
guy who seems like he wanted to be a
librarian but didn't get the job you
know I'm talking about
that's a better way to say it but uh I'm
gonna try this with a voice I might be
like a sommelier of voices and a
sommelier is someone who you know can
taste wine and kind of tell you more
about it okay so I'm gonna go with I'm
gonna go with a third I'm gonna go with
a 29 year old blonde
well breasted well well chested like a
Red Robin you know you ever see that
that Red Robin in your yard and you're
like damn I think shows up around
Thanksgiving around November like damn
and uh it only has kind of one big chest
but it you know that's in in bird
country that's titties you know that's
beautiful but um I'm gonna say well
breasted I'm gonna say around 29 and I'm
gonna say blonde okay that's my just
gasps here we go I'm up here in Northern
California Humboldt County um
stay-at-home mom and also grow a little
bit of indoor marijuana whoo boy man
that turned me on a little bit did I
suddenly I'm crawling for the chips
again you know what I'm saying
suddenly I'm elbow crawling with that
rudder heading for those Tostitos carry
on young lady so yeah enjoy the podcast
think you're funny in town enjoy all the
stand-ups and also your CDs and the
little tidbit of information I'm pretty
sure that your birthday's birthday for
mine so exactly almost birthday brain is
brain oh thank you for that young lady
that's very sweet of you so she's a
stay-at-home mom we'll also grows a
little bit of weed and that's somebody
who listens to this past weekend and
that's true my birthday is coming up on
March 19th March 19th I was born
and I was um you know as a large baby
and so your birthday you said the day
before see yours is the 20th well happy
early birthday to you as well yeah I was
a you know and I had a I had a small rib
cage I remember the doctor told my
mother that he that I had a rib cage of
a large cat and he told her that right
out of the gate and um you know there
was a lot of fear around me when I was
young I think that maybe I wouldn't
develop fully but I've come a long way
but thank you very much for that call
right there and for checking in with us
we also had a gentleman last week that
called in about creep he worked at a
crematorium he said that he was a
listener of this past weekend and and I
had asked him a few facts about
crematoriums and and a crema cremator
is someone who basically I mean it's
that barbecue it's that you know it's
that it's that uh it's that chef it's
that death chef so that cremator man
that's that death that's that death chef
and he grills you up he grills you up
and serves you to the Lord so he said he
would call back with a couple of facts
about working at a crematorium and I
want to hear those right now here we go
what up do is hotdog again no I got
three interesting facts about cremation
for you thank you very much hot dog and
hot dog is a nickname for this man
that's not his legal name more the first
one being if you're a donor meaning like
you got one of them think dots on your
license when you die they basically suck
everything out of you and when I get you
your best damn boy they get that hitter
out of you huh more this was like a meat
bag like a sleeve like a human's sleeves
no bones no organs nothing like that
it's pretty gnarly thing to see it's
like a human leather bag damn boy you
like that like that like that human
Vuitton huh you that human leather bag
that sounds kind of walk hey hold and
then what tell me more real intense
second fact I pretty much break every
bone in the human body every day
brah man you killing me here dude I was
just here I just had a you know a night
you know I just had that wild feeling
going I had that free blood flow from
your girl that called in that
stay-at-home mom was over there baking
brownies you know what I'm saying you
break every bone in the body more it's
kind of gnarly think about people that
when they asked me if I were broken a
bone
you know I see uh all kinds of broken
bones broken skulls
rib fingers you know you name it I break
it and then probably the gnarliest thing
I see is like it's real unfortunate but
when people have miscarriages you know
sometimes they they want them cremated
and everything like that and that is one
cup of work container you don't oh come
on guy
jeepers man whoo that's a to-go box for
the Lord you're talking about man
and I'm sorry guys look I did not hear
these calls in advance so I I didn't
know that I didn't know that was gonna
be in there and I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't know that that was in there and I
would take it out but I'm not gonna take
it out because you know sometimes things
happen
and you know and no offense to you
hotdog you know but you know and I I
mean we're just clowning around here but
yeah that's a heavy thing you know
that's a heavy thing people want to
think about that right now you know
we're trying to celebrate living out
here and this dudes making to-go boxes
out of out of you know out of the Lord's
little ones but you know I believe if
something you know bad happens to a
child that they immediately come back
somewhere you know as another child I
don't think God holds uh you know kids
accountable the same way that he doesn't
an adult you know accountable to certain
afterlife's or something like that and
some people can say oh that's that's
crazy Theo and I disagree with that and
I don't even believe in that's fine you
don't have to believe in any of that
[ __ ] but I believe I believe in any I
anything's possible for me because
here's the thing I showed up here people
like so you're telling me you think you
could show up in a magical world a
heaven where there's you know
everybody's eating you know candy and
jumping
OOP you know and everybody's you know
putting on you know you know skin
softener and feeling nice yeah dude I
showed up here in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere as Joe Rogan puts it on the
middle in the middle of a ball on a ball
of dirt in the middle of nowhere
floating through the galaxy so if this
is possible anything is possible
that's how I look at it the only proof I
have is the experience that I have and
this experience that I would show up out
here where there's all kinds of stuff
there's electricity there shovels
there's wiggers you know there's people
who you know there's people who were
nearsighted people who were farsighted
people who can juggle people doing
backflip people who were afraid to swim
there's shooting stars there's lava
there's cats dude there's [ __ ] cats
you idiot there's snails
there's fruit on trees that just falls
off and dies and nobody ever sees it or
eats it sometimes yeah I think anything
could happen man I really think that
anything could happen but uh but I do
appreciate the other facts man that's
how they do you for the Lord bro they
hollow you out this dudes breaking
people's bones man you gotta be Heat man
what kind of guy do you have to be I bet
you kill it in the UFC bro if you were
in all that in that MMA game bro hot dog
the cremator you know one thing that
always upset me was that if you if you
if you pass away there's only a couple
ways that they that they cremate that
they you know you can be cremated or
buried and that [ __ ] seems weak now I'm
saying one other options bro I would
like to be filled with [ __ ] chocolate
cream you know or I'd like it just if
one of my hands was straight out like it
with a peace sign on it you know real
young Japanese girls style a heart thing
would be great if they [ __ ] bacon you
could be bacon-wrapped you know our
serves all gratin they just put you up
in that casket but with those [ __ ]
cheesy patate surround you I just think
that you know cremation and burial the
only two ways we can do death these days
[ __ ]
but dazzle me okay I won't [ __ ]
sequined up Nick
I want that chin run with somebody to
[ __ ] sharpen my chin people at the
funeral like damn you got a [ __ ]
sharp chin or put a little bottle cap
opener under my chin so people have to
come over there if they want to be or
fine you're gonna get a beer for free at
my funeral but if you want to drink it
you got to come over there and spend
time with Papa no I'm saying I just wish
there were other options then just the
same old option cremation or burial it's
just we live in too high-tech of a time
into advanced into artistic of a world
for those to be the only two options
just cremate me go cremate your [ __ ]
daddy brought your cousin oh [ __ ] that
bro
you know I'm saying I want to be
blackened you know I want to be broiled
bro you know I want that I want that I
want that I Almondine on me you don't
want to be rolling Planko chips and
[ __ ] put out there for the Lord gang
oh but thanks for calling man and thanks
for that information you know I didn't
know some of that no I didn't know some
of that you know when I was young I
remember um I remember the first funeral
that ever went to I had a good friend
when I was young and his brother passed
away his brother was driving in a car
and he was in a car accident and uh and
he passed away man and that [ __ ] shook
me to the core I'm repeating it at the
funeral and I'd never you know I'd never
put it together like how it worked that
people could you know go or people could
pass I'd never here's what it was I'd
never seen how it affected a family and
I went to this funeral and it just it
was heavy right there you know now
remember waiting in line ever he's
waiting on what are people waiting in
line for them as we got closer I realize
we're gonna see the parents and this was
one of my mean this was one of my best
friends when I was a kid this was what
this was his parents and I remember to
says I got closer and closer to his
parents
Filan and they were the nicest they were
the nicest parents of any of my friends
and they they were you know devout
church-going you know devout kind family
first and I you know it just brought I
just remember bawling crying and just
like hugging them you know and I just I
remember just just asking him why this
happened and it just you know I didn't a
moment you know my family would even go
with me my mother didn't even go with me
or anything like that and maybe she
asked me if I wanted her to come and
maybe I said no you know I don't know
maybe she wasn't supposed to come with
me but I don't know if I ever have a 12
year old kid man
or 14 or whatever and he's going to a
service I'm gonna go with him I know
that and I don't hold that against my
mother you know but she just you know
there's always things like that that
were just wild and big and important and
I always was our family was never
connected for him you know that was the
kind of [ __ ] it was like you had to go
out there and this it was just the
emotional streets I was in a lot of
times I felt like like [ __ ] all these
feelings and all this uncertainty and I
don't even know what to do and there's
my buddy's brother laying there and he
was handsome dude I'm not gonna lie my
brother my buddy's brother was [ __ ]
fine as [ __ ] dude you know low-key bruh
he was like the best looking dude around
and even he looked good when he left for
the Lord
you know they had him in a nice suit
probably a suit they got from a net
another town a nearby town where they
had better you know better suit artisans
and better stitchers and better you know
textiles because I didn't grow up in
textile country alright I remember we
had our biggest things in our town
turpentine Birds you could [ __ ] get a
bird dude you wanted a free bird get one
[ __ ] they're out there and other things
in our town was they had um it was
supposed to be the world's longest slide
some man had just taken a bunch of
regular slides and put them together
and some kid [ __ ] cut his leg open on
it and it wasn't I don't know if it was
ever documented or not but it was shady
as [ __ ] that thing was a piece of [ __ ]
and then what else did we have Lee
Harvey Oswald went to our middle school
Pistol Pete Maravich his sons lived in
my in my in my town what else that was
it really you know that was really it of
our town but but I just remember that uh
that was just heartbreaking that was
like the first funeral I ever went to so
I didn't mean to get into this man I
know is gonna talk about this you know
in its springtime and uh it's springtime
and so you know we're just thinking
about new things and and Here I am just
reminiscing about the past but yeah you
know anything's possible now you know I
guess spring is like a thing of rebirth
so you know it's okay I guess that we're
talking about this because you know if
you believe in being you know
reincarnation or being reborn until like
another you know more comfortable place
after this I believe it I believe I
believe in something you know I'm saying
I'm not gonna stop nice you think you're
just gonna shut me down here on earth
I'll see you in the future cat daddy you
shutting me down here on earth bruh I'm
about to hit all nine of these planets
dude I'm about to hit I'll [ __ ] live
on the moon bro I'll show up on a moon
and must live everywhere so you can
catch me on that reincarnation on that
rebirth bus you can catch me in heaven
one heaven to having three heaven for
I'll be out there so I'm not stopping
baby you know I didn't come this far to
stay where I am you know that what else
ma'am I want to tell you this man you
know there's a gentleman on with this
company and it's called laughable and
he's this is not this is not a promotion
for this is not he didn't pay me for
this and but I just want to say that
it's a great app it's a great app to
stay in touch with good comedians if you
haven't already downloaded the laughable
app go get it right now just say hey
Siri download laughable it takes five
seconds or just search for laughable in
the App Store it's the best rated
podcast
for the iPhone by far you can search for
me or any other comedian and find all
the podcasts they've been on as a host
or as a guest so give laughable a shot
they got good people over there and they
you know I touch base with them and they
give me some guidance and thoughts and
stuff and uh and they got good people so
check in with laughable man what else is
going on I'll tell you this in the news
I saw Bruno Mars they're saying he's you
know cultural appropriation that he's
kind of playing up like it you know that
he leads people to believe I guess that
he's african-american and then he's not
and well first of all he leads people to
believe he's a planet he's lost him as
Mars so ain't buying that that [ __ ] so
while I mean who KN ever you know I
definitely figured he was authentic I
also figured he could have been you know
a short white dude in a lot of makeup I
don't give a [ __ ] man you know when you
really think about the whole world's
culturally appropriate everything we all
use in something we're all out here
freelancing some of this cultural
appropriation said I'm like and it did
if you want to call out anybody for
cultural appropriation call out
Hollywood they've been making dimes off
with cats for that if that they mean
come on do if you look back on some of
these contracts boy every color of skin
has been taking advantage of and if you
want it in and then the further you go
down the skin tone line I'm sure the
worse the contracts have been over the
years I bet if you were to look at that
you know mom black friends some of my
black friends we're begging to get on
the Oscars two years ago or Awards
remember that so you know but then this
is you know I don't know if we can't go
back in time with a time machine then we
can't really adjust the past so until we
get [ __ ] time travel we need to work
with solution buddy talking about this
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm talking about
[ __ ] it I should've brought it up Bruno
Mars I like Bruno Mars do you know Bruno
Mars to me seems like sexually am M
you know homogeny no ambiguous
ambidextrous you know I'm saying he
seemed like the kind of dude that would
just tie his dick around his own body
and put it in his butt you know he's got
that well he's everything he's like that
you know he might also have a vagina in
each pocket you know he's like he seemed
like that kind of guy
I like Bruno Mars my guys entertaining
as hell what else man I guess oh I
remember when I was young people in my
town for daylight saving time people
some people didn't know what it was you
know in my neighborhood where they had
some real they had people [ __ ] you
know definitely a lot of people sharing
ideas like if you wanted an idea you
better go down the street and borrow
from somebody you know a lot of people
weren't coming up with their own
thoughts in my neighborhood and I
remember this one dude furious bro he
might have been on some uppers he might
have been drinking out of of got out of
a car battery I don't know you know cuz
they had these dudes for a while that
would empty out a car battery and then
they would put a beer in there and then
drink it out of the battery so you get a
little bit of that that hit of that
battery acid with also with your
beverage you know and these people were
just you know they were just losing
steam man they were just starting to
fall off the bone you know because
something was getting wrong with them
because of some of that battery acid
this one dude I remember daylight
savings time came outside shotgun just
started shooting at the Sun you know
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is shooting at the Sun
dude furious Brooke couldn't figure it
out you know Saint he been cheated and
all this [ __ ] so you never know you
never know what you need to get out
there man you know and I told him I said
straight up man everybody loses the hour
it ain't just you boy you know you get
off your own ego because everybody loses
the damn hour sound like you're [ __ ]
living in the future all of a sudden or
in the past you [ __ ] Muppet get it
together everybody loses the hour I'm
gonna tell you guys I'll be in Tacoma
this weekend at that took home a comedy
club and that's March 15th and 16th
March 17th I'll be at the Spokane
Spokane comedy club levity live has been
canceled April 6th and 7th I'll be in
Tampa Florida at
Brothers brewing April 20th and 21st
Hasbrouck Heights New Jersey and that is
somewhere in Jersey June 15th and 16th
double Yuk Yuk's in Calgary and that
Calgary Alberta Canada also I want to
tell you who's listening to the podcast
I got this message that came in it said
good evening from Maine and I went to
Maine one time and killed a bat killed a
a bat with a tennis racket one time when
I was trying to touch a girl's vagina
for the first time in an abandoned attic
and that's true good evening from Maine
I'm a lobster boat captain and I have an
audio system set up on my boat for my
crew and I to listen to music while we
tend our lobster traps but now we use
the audio system to catch up on this
past weekend keep up the good work and
congrats on the new studio best regards
captain Nick Perrault FV Invictus
Jonesport Maine a man that's a good that
that's nice thank you guys for checking
it out man and thank you guys for being
out there catching lobsters because you
know I'm saying lot like I grew up in
shrimp country you know I grew up where
they had those little mounds out you
know they had these little castles
outside of the ditch and inside of those
you can find a shrimp a crawfish you
know and a crawfish is just a violent
[ __ ] shrimp a crawfish is just a
shrimp that's been a prison you know a
crawfish is just a I mean a crawfish is
you give a shrimp a sword a helmet a
battle-axe and a dirty Dancy tail bang
that's a crawfish and a crawfish will
beat the F out of a shrimp and beat the
U and the C and the K out of shrimp a
crawfish is everything all right it's a
damn Lannister and a crawfish its
crawfish season right now actually so
get out there and get that hitter you
know if you if you're in a place where
you can eat them but they have these
little castles in the ditch with a hole
in it and the crawfish would get in
there you could get out there it's like
your first time you would ever go catch
something you know people will put a
little piece of ham or something on this
line and put it down that hole and wait
till that crawdad latched onto it and
pull it up but that was our Lobster if
you got a fat crawfish that was them
laying lobsters you know
captain perrault and so if you guys are
out there hunting lobsters do more power
to you get out there and get him you
know I heard a story one time about a
lobster that my buddy found said they
caught a lobster and had a pearl in it
had a pearl in it from you know I guess
sandy got into its body somehow the same
way it gets into a oyster and this
lobster had a pearl and he started doing
this whole thing he was thinking lobster
pearls you know he's gonna be the next
big thing so he bought a ton of [ __ ]
lobsters and none of the rest of them
had pearls in them so it also could have
just been a lobster you know it was
downstream from a jewelry shop and
caught a [ __ ] hit of a bracelet but I
know he lost a a bunch of money doing
that and I probably should've said that
Tim if you listen to this I'm sorry too
but anyhow thank you guys for listening
Captain Perrault out there a couple
YouTube shoutouts man Christie Garcia
she said I forgot my headphones at home
and because I have to listen to you
guess who left work and went to the gas
station for headphones Gang Gang you
said Brendan is an Instagram model I did
and he is burn and shout another guy
Crowsnest 89 the ultimate con man TF 80k
new suit new studio looks simple as [ __ ]
though you know when Tom Sawyer had to
paint the fence but he schemed those
other dudes into thinking it was fun you
just did that with their studio but let
me get this studio in y'all this
spacious a [ __ ] right cheer you're
awesome keep us laughing thank you guys
for that thank you guys for checking in
on that stuff we're going to get into
some calls but first I want to tell you
star flow the location for fans trying
to link up and get closer to their
favorite celebrities star flow is a
safer ecosystem where your information
won't be sold on the black market or
other markets star flow is a safer
ecosystem it provides a hub for
consumers to access their favorite
talents and celebrities and exclusive
content in seconds
available on the app or at star flow
comm star flow stays out of the cell
your informations secondary market and
it's a safe place where algorithms and
sneaky pixels that secretly use your own
searches and information to sell you
stuff aren't allowed it's all about
users creators and content check it out
in the App Store or at Star flow dot-com
all right before we get to your calls I
want to check in I want to make a call
and this is this young lady smoking cigs
you guys got to get to know where I'm
trying to get her in a studio so I
figured I'd give her a ring first her
Instagram to me I mean it just is
hilarious she's just one of a con she's
a rare element you know if say if
plutonium were you know kind of you know
finger-banging
floor up fluorine or whatever and they
secretly had you know they fell in love
and had a baby this baby would be with
that rare element that's who she is
right here smoking cigs and and simon
rex turned me on newer Dirt Nasty
somebody knew him as Dirt Nasty
assignment is um a buddy of mine he's
just a real I mean just a genuine
hummingbird of talent and humanity and
he turned me on newer and so I want to
reach out to her right now
see what's up with this hello what's up
SIG's its Theo what's crackin not much
baby girl I heard you're headed to Los
Angeles yeah now when do you touch down
here I already already done you know how
I like that one bitchin Bad Girls Club
so she runs our leg no no [ __ ] smoking
623 [ __ ] I run la oh you got you got
competition huh yeah yeah she got
competition oh yeah I mean you know like
my thing is I walk up in the room
there's no such thing as competition 31
you know oh yeah I've seen you you're
like a little hail you're like a menthol
hailstorm you know I'm sorry I've seen
you show up now I just want to get an
update now where you at right now were
you at these days you still like I am
okay Spring Break 2k 18 like you already
know it's problem and what's the big
drug right now out there
with the kids Wow amend other day okay
right yeah it's like it's like corn
store right it's over in opa-locka and
like so it's just like it looks like
corn store but that you go in the back
and there's like this door and then they
are like a little peephole
it sounds like members-only and [ __ ]
like you know commas cracking right and
it's like this like really shitty bar
right yeah then like well to counter and
they only have like mode ellos and like
like vodka cranberries but then they do
serve as coat and I shoot 24 hours that
[ __ ] is jumping
they got one of them view box machines
you know you probably called our black
you're living you don't know I was up in
that [ __ ] like midnight till 9
a.m. the next day
man I should whip cracking oh I can feel
that tell me now tell me that they got a
daycare in there I know they got a
daycare up next oh I love it now so what
brick what are you what are you doing
out here in Los Angeles I know that you
and Simon Rex are buddies and you guys
are out here um you know trying to what
what are you guys up to
well I got media we made a show and we
bought a cell that [ __ ] we already met
with MTV vh1 we mean up with Iceland I
think we gone too complex that Verizon
[ __ ] everywhere Smith & Wesson sponsored
by Smith & Wesson baby I don't care who
I got extort you know what I'm saying
yeah buy this [ __ ] by in these
[ __ ] I think you deserve it I
mean you're definitely one of the
wildest cats that I've ever seen you
know for sure right now what kind of got
ask you what kind of dude sliding here
it's sliding in your DMS because you're
a specific weird-ass [ __ ] off
on my debt on the daily baby like what
them sit properly doesn't let's do you
don't I'm saying I mean everybody be
fired up a lot of brothers a lot of
brothers thank you a lot of brothers a
lot of brothers you know here's my thing
don't be signing up my D
about their pots mine you know that I
ain't mean up with you unless you got
that verify shot or you got a record
deal let somebody teach you that fair
fight on your own time yeah and gang
girl sound fire robbers mm-hmm no unless
you got that verified sign you need
somebody real I mean I need at least 1
million total views up on your
soundcloud before you can slide up into
these the end well I guess you gotta aim
high now where did you get that like
where'd you get that desire to aim high
like where did that start for you you
know bad it's like me you know you can't
I can't I can't just being seen by
anybody you know I'm Sam yeah I do know
that and do you have a man these days or
what's up
no no not I mean you know I'm waiting
I'm waiting for mr. right to come around
you know me yeah you gotta have money
mm-hmm
and are you giving like if a man comes
along and you do you do the one-night
stand kind of thing will you drop a
[ __ ] on a fellow if he deserves it or
what don't don't don't be coming towards
me you know that makes you guys take me
to Applebee's and you must [ __ ]
take me to TGIF Friday for dessert are
you switching venues you switching
venues right that's all I'm saying we
switch of venues up in this [ __ ] time
yeah I do 100% now what's up like uh
like when I was growing up they had a
lot of haters and everything out there
they still is it still pretty hater
specific out there yeah in reality
everybody loves me on time right
I got family's Australia I got fan base
to Europe I got base in the Taliban
Afghanistan
they'll all be loving the ciggies the
gays love me the guys love me the the
freaks love me the hipsters love me now
all [ __ ] love me I love it
well I love you and I appreciate you uh
I appreciate you jumping on the line
with us you got an arm you got a come in
studio next time you come in if you
can't make it in this week then next
time yeah all right we'll look fly safe
and I'll see you with Simon we're gonna
all grab lunch
all right baby good
are you that and that cigs man look you
can follow her on Instagram eat some of
y'all are listening right now and you be
like that
you know she's that thing you know you
know whatever her voice is all over the
place she's wild dude I'm telling you go
to her Instagram it is smoking SM okay I
in CI GS 23 and I mean she should be
brought to you by percocet okay cuz she
is I mean as simon rex introduced her to
me and he said man she's like the
realest one you will ever meet and she
is [ __ ] i mean she's she's a but i
mean i would love to see her like in a
UFC fight or something because she'll
lose but you know that she would be good
boy you know that [ __ ] would be good
just the way in a loan would be better
than half the fights that are out there
all right let's get to some of you
guys's calls that came in right here
here on the hotline here we go a CEO man
it's your boy Justin from Jersey Justin
from Jersey
dude I tell you it is so I was in
Clifton one time and that's a place in
New Jersey right I was in Clifton New
Jersey and this girl I was at Joey's I'm
gonna for anybody remembers night color
this nightclub in Joey's they had spread
they had tanning beds by the front door
when you went in they had three beds
doing that people entertaining some
people just go that it's Han other
people are dancing some people are
[ __ ] one person is giving birth to a
baby that's also tanning the baby's
tanning so just a crazy place man they
spray everybody down with banana lotion
like halfway through the dance night
it's insane uh and I met this girl this
beautiful Italian girl
I mean alright you could eat [ __ ] I
mean you'd clean skin I mean you'd
[ __ ] suck marinara out of her ear
holes
you know stunning and so she you know we
were flirting and I was drinking man I
would I was drinking and I was lit up
and I was you know she was letting me
touch her you know kind of touch her bud
and touch her you know breasts a little
bit in the club you know over the shirt
and then she let me touch her friends
but which I thought and her friend was
you know cool with that and so I thought
that was [ __ ] awesome you know like
I'm touching her butt and then she's
like hey touch my friends but I'm like
yeah dang there's four cheeks out here
for daddy boy you know it's like just
playing the bongos out here anyway she
takes me home over there in New Jersey
she takes me back to her mother's house
wherever she lives I don't know I was I
was lit up it's like a 40-minute Drive
and this is back when you could drunk
drive and we so we get there man I
remember she and I we got another
basement and the basement was like an
l-shaped basement so we get into the
basement it's like an L shape and I
don't know I can't remember if we hooked
up or whatever in this bed down there
there's a bed in the in there in the
corner of the L shape
you know the basement kind of goes one
way and then there's a you know it's an
L makes an L and in that corner where
the two legs met there was a bed and so
I get in that bed I fell asleep or
whatever in the morning I wake up and on
one side I hear like this sound like a
lawnmower sound like a like a kind of a
gay lawnmower and it's a hair dryer
somebody's running a hair dryer like two
hair dryers there's somebody running a
salon in the corner of the basement
right so I'm like holy [ __ ] like who are
these people then at the other corner of
the basement there's a Bible study going
on there's just like a writ there's like
four or five kids sitting around doing a
Bible study it looks like Jesus boy this
is about is G you know hit me with a you
know a couple a couple hundred
milligrams a test 200 milliliters a test
200 and some wind straw and this is
about the most New Jersey experience you
could have but that was something that
happened man I woke up in that L shape
you know and though that's that's
basically the Lord saying look it's time
to braid your spirit you know it's time
to cornrow your soul a little bit and
get right but uh but that was a good
time that I had out there in Jersey but
thank you for calling Justin homeward
the reason I'm calling is I wanted to
know your opinion and your stance your
your whole you know
your idea of marijuana and cannabis and
the industry and legalization and all
that because I'm very passionate about
it um it's helped over a drug addiction
of my eyes to be addictive an axe and it
really helped me on maintain a
productive lifestyle and be a better
person okay cool
my opinions on me yeah look if we worked
for you that's fine you know right now
I'm sober so I can't do marijuana I mean
I can if I want to but I'm choosing not
to at this point and will that change it
might change you know but for right now
you know it hasn't worked for me in the
past now I'd also might have weed might
of refined itself into a better position
but I get that anxiety well I get it you
know I turned into you know that spooky
boy I turn it into that dude who was
playing hide and go seek by himself you
know in the house at a small dinner
party that guy you know that guy just
runs up to you out of the blue ones like
hey go count don't count you know that
guy so I don't handle handle it well but
I am I think you know we're headed in a
huge direction for more natural medicine
I think it's a scary time out there
there's a lot of companies coming out
with fake stuff and not good products
but I think you just got to find one
that you trust and one that you know is
good but yeah these CBD oils and all of
that kind of stuff you know I consider
getting into those types of things and
figuring out more about that and I'm
open to it man you know I think I think
the only reason that we've only had the
certain drugs that we've had is because
scient the government you know probably
has had better control over them
you know when the government's had taxes
in place out of the gate so yeah I'm all
for more I wish they would come out with
like neater drugs you know some of these
natural drugs but now I do think that if
you that drug abuse is a real thing and
if you ain't doing if you got dreams but
you ain't doing [ __ ]
you know sometimes drugs don't help that
you know where if you got you know
things you want to do when you you know
you just
you know if you always you if your first
excuse is to go get high then maybe
that's not it but [ __ ] you know these
mushrooms expand in people's minds and
helping people see a softer side of the
world and I'm all for that man I think
there's a lot of exploration that needs
to be done out there and I'm glad that
were that there's a lot of people
getting into it and we're getting back
to a lot of more natural stuff so you
don't need these pharmacies to go you
know to go to that [ __ ] and get that
[ __ ] you know you can beat and it's
nice to hear that you know you were on a
pharmaceutical and now you're on
something natural something from the
earth and that's beautiful because that
seems like a way more comfortable thing
to be associating with your body you
know something that's you know that's
just that's more of nature not this you
know this [ __ ] out there these you know
people out here on hydroxy codone and
Hydroxycut you know people do you know
it's scary very scary man and drug
addiction and that kind of stuffs been
heavy in my family and it's scary and
it's a scary world and anybody that
struggling with that kind of stuff you
feel free hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
you know I'm not license I don't know
anything like that but but I you know
I'd love to hear from you I just I want
you to feel alone if you're having a
tough time with something like that but
thanks for calling Justin you know it's
nice to know that there are people out
there like you are advocates and who
were pushing hard you know and I watch
some of these guys I'll watch them feel
good and I watch them you know I think
you have to be able to find what works
for you and it seemed like you found
that and if you're in a comfortable
space for you then that's awesome
brother all right let's get another call
here here we go
what up do that IRA down in Phoenix
Arizona IRA what's up brother
I think it's is it a could be German
maybe could be Hebrew IRA
that's also a you know it's a good place
if you guys don't have one open you can
open one up and hide some of your money
there if you have an S corp so I think
you or you don't have to have that I
think you just have a regular if it be a
human with a social security number you
can put some money away a nice place of
savings and I know that's probably a bad
joke that people tell you all the time
IRA now didn't mean to just Delvin
that but it reminded me that I got to
finish my taxes let's hear more so I got
this dilemma with my wife she you know
put the dress on the other day she's a
petite little figure you know 130 pounds
sopping wet maybe okay you got a petite
thing in a dress boy already I'm
interested let's hear more and you put
this dress on the other day what are you
coming up this Friday and it's a little
tighter of midsection you know so she
had a little donut popping out okay so
she got that little donut out front and
I sell him I like that I like that
little front hump you know I like that
lady I got that soft batch blowing out
the front you know she got that Center
you know she got that soft that that
soft Center I like that man
all right let's hear more and everything
since he's been on this ketosis diet but
the first thing to go are the fun bags
and the but Douglas you know so I don't
really know what to do should I keep
supporting her to get giddy or should I
tell her to plump back up a little bit
okay so you're saying your ladies on
that ketosis and that sound like the
dark arts to me boy ketosis dude for I
mean I'm guessing up for cancer I would
say look man there's better there's
easier ways probably lose weight then
you know doing you know stuff like that
you know doing it you know heavy
treatments I mean cancer drugs that kind
of that kind of stuff is that's for
cancer dude and to be you know to be
using you should probably talk to a
metal medical professional
because we using that kind of stuff to
lose weight [ __ ] just run or
something you know but the second part
of that that losing weight sometimes you
lose them tits you lose them but
jugglers yeah well you can't have it all
man you know if you want that you know
that thick stick then you got to enjoy
that yeah I mean look some of these
skinny ladies it's like making love to a
to a bag of uh to a pillowcase full of
deer antlers so you know I'm saying they
get too lean
it's like you're out there you know just
trying to weave through a woodpile with
a dead so you want a lady that's got a
little bit of heat on her you know you
want a little bit of lady that's got a
little bit of rib meat and even a little
bit of leg meat on her ribs that's fine
I'm saying there nothing wrong with that
you know the biggest thing is just
getting in that mood putting on a couple
candles putting on some you know I used
to [ __ ] I used to honestly brides to
listen to NBA jams a lot when I would
[ __ ] a little bit that a madra shot I
put that [ __ ] on brush something about
those dunks and Shawn Kemp and all that
[ __ ] made me want to [ __ ] but I you know
you gotta just that's the thing you got
to get it you know you got to get
comfortable in there so I think whatever
you're doing get comfortable bring them
lights down you know I'm saying I don't
you know and just tell you girl your
lover she don't need to be out doing all
that kind of [ __ ] that's like cutting
your leg off to lose weight you know
you're gonna lose 30 pounds but you're
not gonna have a leg you're gonna be
[ __ ] hop into work you know so it's
that's hit or miss man let's take
another call with you here we go this
past Thursday got kicked out of my mom's
and her husband's house and just staying
at these damn motels and hotels two
different hotels this past weekend okay
so this past weekend this guy's calling
in about this past weekend and we said
if people wanted to call in and tell us
what their weekend was like if it was
good or bad that I at the end of the
month each month we would do a contest
we would send you one of these shirts
and I don't have it right here in front
of me we got these straight up these
correctional blue these Correctional
Center blue hitters and we'll mail one
out to you whoever has had the best or
worst weekend so you need to leave me a
leave us a message on the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five oh
three and we'll send you one whoever
wins and this I believe is our first
entry of it and you just leave that
message and here we go and so yesterday
last night I had the homie come through
burn some trees a little bit at the
hotel and he decides you want to go see
black panther okay so you got you and
your boy you got kicked out of the house
and now you're at the hotel motel you
live in on your own and your boy can't
do to burn a little bit of green go all
right and you're going to see Black
Panther two times so you definitely not
racist so that's
I said for homework I was pumped high
but relieved and my dumb ass started
speeding almost 20 over I think a little
less but they always want to say was
more you know they always want to tell
you is more men they always want to tell
you is more one time this man pulled me
over and this girl that had gotten in
the car and she wouldn't shut up and I
was yelling at her you know and the man
pulled me over he's like you you know
you were swerving back there why were
you doing that and I said cuz this [ __ ]
wouldn't shut it down this one right
here sir [ __ ] Margaret right here
Margaret and he look bro and he's like I
feel you man and that was it dude let me
off true story but onward bro you got
pulled over
I was weed currently these cops started
to change their minds he said we're not
arresting people and you work a little
you know dime bags and joints tell them
there's nothing in the cars I really
thought that wasn't so he ends up taking
us out searching us searching the car
finds a joint luckily he's still cool
about it telling me to stomp it out and
he sent us on our way after about an
hour and a half
not to mention I had told the girl that
he me at the movie theater but uh I
already been like an hour and happened
in the movie by the time they were done
so I could tell just over text barely
replying she didn't respond to my call
so that's been that's been a pretty
rough weekend okay that sound like a
rough weekend you got pulled over by the
cops you know you were going that you
were speeding you invited a girl to the
movies and you didn't show up your
parents kicked you out the house man
that sounds shitty Brennan also sounds
like you got to get more organized man
you got to get on your [ __ ] you know you
got to get on your [ __ ] man I can
already you know I'm jumping in
conclusions here but you seem like a
just a white dude that's not being on
his [ __ ] and you need to get on it
your stepparents give you living with
the family bro tighten up okay get up 45
minutes earlier help out around the
house be a part of the solution at your
house dude if you out there blowing them
blowing getting high and you busting up
on that grass and lung it up on that
green ring then at least [ __ ] drive
the speed limit all right we don't need
a [ __ ] you know we don't need some do
this you know hopped up on all of this
[ __ ] out there you know playing Mario
Kart out there so you know I'm saying
ride the speed limit you got a friend in
the car
and you out there you know being wild
and throwing banana peels it they're out
the window and [ __ ] trying to [ __ ]
you know you know trying to bump into
the princess get it together man and
then the last part you invited a girl of
the movie and you know that kind of [ __ ]
happens bro you know I would call her
and I was just explaining to her what
happened call her explain to her what
happened say look how [ __ ] up you know
I'm getting high too much you know I'm
not taking care of my [ __ ] my parents
threw me out I'm living at motels I'm
blowing trees over at a motel and
speeding and missing dates you know you
got it man
but I love you dude that's the crazy
part bro I [ __ ] love you dude I
really do
cuz I've been you I've been there I've
been there man I think anyway maybe I
haven't I don't know made some poor
choices dude but if you're young man
does have you know I think just you know
just hold it together this don't don't
don't don't you know take care of
yourself that's the main thing just take
care of yourself get things in a little
more moderation that's what I mean get
yourself in a comfortable spot go make
it up to that lady you know maybe she if
she showed up go make it up to her you
know just take you know take a little
bit of responsibility you know what will
follow after that a little bit more we
just start to want it regular you'll
start to get a taste for that you got a
little bit of hit of that responsibility
on your tongue I know you can do it man
you got this [ __ ] what else man this
call came in I'll play this thing for
Vaughn no from Los Angeles this is Knoll
from Los Angeles and I've never met
anybody named Knowle more I got real
excited when you started saying [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them trying to hold you down
and I completely agree but this year or
whatever it is it's just a flavor of the
year this is people's flavors right now
what they got going on in people's
flavor not a poor white kid from
Louisiana or you know a 34 year old
white kid from the south side of Chicago
but we're just going to keep refining
our tools we're going to keep common
we're going to
keep work and we're going to keep doing
what we do because we're not going to
let some [ __ ] punk ass [ __ ]
hold us from our dream I miss you
brother I think you're the [ __ ]
funniest guy out there behind Sebastian
and I just I love you and I appreciate
everything that you do
thanks know I appreciate it man you know
and yeah and this goes for look it's not
because we're you know Noel said he said
he's a white guy it's not because you
know he's a white guy I'm a white guy
you know it's just anything I you know
it's just you if anything this a lot of
this experiences made me feel like what
it's like to not feel welcome and that
sucks man you know it sucks not feeling
welcome
but the problem is where I can where I
can mess up is when I start to act like
I'm not welcome because when I start to
act like I'm not welcome that's when I'm
not taking care of myself
so if DIF some places or people don't
want to take care of me they don't want
to make me feel welcome because of where
I'm from or the way I sound or the way
that I look then that's their choice but
if I start to let that live in me in a
negative way and that's my choice so man
I really can really you know and this in
some ways this is some of this is a
unique way that I've ever related to
people who have not been allowed
something because of their or felt like
they weren't allowed something because
of their because of their skin or their
voice or their where they're from and
I'm not comparing this to any other
anybody else's walk in this universe I'm
gonna compare this but I'm but I am
sharing what I would have said what's
happening for me because that's what's
real to me you know and it you know it
is it's wild man it makes me you know it
definitely teaches me a lot about you
know I mean I can empathize now I can
empathize when people say man you know I
don't feel welcome I don't feel like
these people want me like they don't
accept me you know but I thought you
know I hope that we all get back to a
day where it's just all that it's about
is who's the most entertaining and I
think that's what comedies always been
usually
and a lot of times I think the people
that's get in this show or this or that
man that's who they want but I think
these days we live in a world where
people are finding out you know who is
out there putting in the work and who is
out there doing what's good and that's
it man that's how I think that that's it
for today that's it for today you know
we'll probably be back with a Thursday
episode we got the new studio coming
along we got a couple guests books I
don't think it's going to happen this
week but I don't know you know but yeah
some cool stuff man I want to thank
everybody who helps out on patreon we we
now have two cameras we got another mic
that just came in cool stuff happening a
lot of cool stuff happening and a lot of
it's all thanks to you guys I cannot
thank you I cannot thank you enough
I want to thank gray block pizza for
their support I'll excuse me I'll see
you guys in Tacoma at the comedy club
this weekend I want to thank everybody
that called in for everybody's thoughts
I wanted another shout out to Justin
last week who called in his brother had
passed away man still thinking about you
you know and still you know I just
appreciate you sharing that with us
because it's you know it's moments like
that that are real it's moments like
that that are really really really real
and really put things into perspective
and I hope that uh you know that you're
finding some peace in your heart bro I
really do
that's it man that's all we got today be
good to yourselves you probably deserve
it I'm gonna take you out with some of
that original hit that we had and that
is a Spencer Jacob growl with celebrate
[Music]
oh thank you guys man for being here
with me I appreciate it really do
[Music]
celebrate man
we all die
celebrate our days celebrate our
demons
let's
[Music]
be good to yourselves man you probably
deserve it